y anoche hubo sufrimiento en el palmar
murcia en el este de españa la gente se
comía las uñas literalmente ahí en la
tierra natal de alcaraces del pueblo de
24 mil habitantes vibró con el triunfo
de su hijo ilustre este es el momento en
el que consigue la victoria allí se
instaló esta pantalla gigante para que
la multitud pudiera disfrutar de esa
final y vemos que efectivamente lo
disfrutaron así es juan y seguimos
hablando de alcaraz porque
definitivamente está rompiendo todas las
barreras así si se está ganando el
cariño de muchísima afición que al
carlos alcaraz ascendió desde la cuarta
plaza hasta el número uno del mundo en
este abierto de eeuu es desde ese lunes
el jugador más joven en estar en lo más
alto del ranking de la atp con apenas 19
años y cuatro meses superando el récord
que tenía el australiano lleyton hewitt
con 20 años y nueve meses además de este
editor carlos alcaraz es el campeón de
grand slam más joven desde que lo
hiciera rafael nadal en 2005 con 19 años
y 2 días es el campeón del abierto de
eeuu más joven desde sampras que
tenía 19 años y un mes
alcaraz es el líder de victorias de
victorias este año con 51 y también
lidera ahora el número de títulos de la
temporada con 5 rompiendo el empate que
tenía con rafael nadal que cuenta con 4
rafael nadal que tiene una academia y de
esa academia nació casa salió casas
perro que llegó con 19 años